thank you to our sponsor ZocDoc ZocDoc
is the only free app that lets you find
and book doctors who are patient
reviewed take your insurance are
available when you need them and treat
almost every condition Under the Sun go
to zocdoc.com trash and download the
ZocDoc app for free then find and book a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that's
zocdoc.com trash
are you ready for a good time without
the guesswork order your THC products
from mood today for 20 off your first
order and free gummies go to
hellomood.com and use promo code trash
Tuesday that's
hellomood.com promo code trash Tuesday
for 20 off your order and free gummies
all right hey sluggies I am on the road
I'm going to be in Baltimore at
Magooby's June 2nd and 3rd I'll be in
Salt Lake City Wise Guys Comedy Club
June 9th and 10th I'll be in San Antonio
Texas at the LOL Comedy Club June 23rd
and 24th I'll also be in Philadelphia
Those ads are going up
um I I'm gonna be in The Great Outdoors
Comedy Festival in Calgary with Andrew
Schultz in August and my tickets to
Austin have gone on sale for October we
got a lot more dates coming up so go to
annieleterman.com shows and you can see
me on my solo podcast anniewood every
Thursday come hang out with me and Todd
I'll see you there hi slugs I am so
excited that I'm back on the road I've
been working on my stand-up cannot wait
to share these freakishly weird ideas
with you I will be in Atlanta on June
3rd I'll be in Raleigh one night only
June 4th New York City at the iconic
Joe's Pub for intimate really fun like
theatery shows July 19th through 22nd DC
Improv and then Wilbur in Boston which
is a huge deal for me I'm so excited to
see you guys we're gonna have so much
fun hanging out and you can get tickets
at Esther onice.com
[Music]
I have a question because I know you
guys aren't as messy as me I think it
goes on you don't know you don't know I
mean I think you are like have Asian
mother in you though I can that is true
that it can only be messy for so long
but do you have mommy thing because I
don't know if I feel like either you or
Dave has it Todd has it with me but like
do you it's like the mom thing where you
can go like where's my pink sock and
they're like oh it's under the like
there's always like oh I am a person is
it Dave no I don't if I ask him or
something like I don't I would never ask
him where something is because I would
get humiliated on the spot what would he
say like if ever kind of like a whole
writer's room
I'm like oh my God I can't find blank
he's like if he hears me say that from
another room I will hear him go oh
that's so weird oh you can't find
something like he there's shame in that
but with my mom does he always find
things does he always know where things
are his things yeah yeah okay wait what
what's your so Todd knows where your
stuff is Todd it has the mom thing where
he knows like under like he'll be under
five layers I know where something else
so do you have that well I'm I was that
to Bobby and he would oh here's the
thing so in therapy my therapist is like
you cannot do that for him anymore it's
causing a lot of resentment but then he
would do this and he and then she said
Bobby you cannot also start freaking out
and demanding that she finds something
for you yeah but then from across the
room I hear like oh
my day is ruined and and then I have to
and then my therapist is like when you
hear that do not just walk away it is
not your problem don't take the trip but
then he follows me he knows I'm with an
earshot and he has a fit and I always
break I'm always like [__] what is it
what did you lose this time I couldn't
find my keys or I can't find my wallet
and then I go on like a treasure I can
imagine him doing this when you don't
even live together now oh no he still
does it he absolutely at least still
does it but okay so but okay now that
you're you're not you don't have him to
do it for in your presence yeah do you
feel like maybe you're letting loose now
you're letting your inner Bobby come out
a little bit a little bit and I think
Jules is paying the price
um because it's oh Jules get to work
Jules come on did you want to come to
this country oh my God Jules
that's the exact speech I give her
actually
you think this is all for free
I've made you a star you made her a star
oh Bobby did we by the way Dave's nephew
is officially going to college in La
starting this fall I don't know why I
thought you're gonna say moving in with
you I was like this is a crazy twist
like I like his nephew is gonna be like
in our lives how old is he 18 yes
that is true Esther you go in when
you're 18 and you come out when you're
30 days
things happen guys I was in college for
wait what school and is he living in the
dorm he's gonna go to Occidental and
he's living in the dorms
sounds like a Jewish accident doesn't it
Occidental is it's accidental it's a
good school Orthodox accident great um
area Eagle Rock
yeah I'm burying the lead his nephew is
like really cute
oh my God Esther's gonna start dating
her her looks age
no I'm joking I am excited like it is
weird having like a young man
is that what you mean like when because
you know when he was like kind of a kid
right yeah and then they turned him and
you're like I don't want to talk to you
anymore no totally like but I'm almost
like is he are we gonna be friends like
how do you befriend a teenager I mean I
we would ask you that why would you ask
us that that's true you're the one I
don't know dress like them wait so I
know should we introduce today's theme
yeah please because I'm [__] dying in
this so make me a burger [__] we're I
can barely breathe this feels like a
corset that's what I want that's what I
want when I have a burger made for me I
want someone to be like I feel like I'm
dying and I just want to add that I
needed help from Bryce to put this on
why are you sexually assaulting all of
our people it's not by choice they hand
me this extra extra small thing to wear
and I can't put it over my body and they
know I've been bulking I'm in my bulking
phase you guys it does look good when
you were doing your little sachet out
yesterday I was like okay we're dying
we're Diner waitresses today we are
um there was an incident with Annie's
costume and she's a prisoner yes I'm the
fat one okay wait can we see at least
what you were supposed to get into it's
by the way this was divine intervention
this didn't fit
I feel like you why can I just say what
I thought this was gonna be I thought
Esther had that [__] cute you had
like the best outfit ever from your
Johnny Rocket dates well so from your TV
show from alone together but I didn't
get to keep that dear Liz thank you Liz
I can't we put that in our contracts now
like that we know okay we have no the
writers are striking nobody has leverage
it's so you picking actually is making
me laugh so hard I have to pick it after
this probably in this outfit wait I'm
picking with Jean where are you
picketing I think Netflix she okay
wait we should coordinate pickets Annie
are we are we gonna trash Tuesday
guys I can't read
okay I'm trying to get everyone to stop
writing and reading or whatever to be
like me this was my outfit it would have
been pitted out these would have been
Yellow by the way I think you could fit
it I couldn't no it's I'm telling you
Esther she's not wrong the backs of it
this barely went over you have a petite
shoulder thing going on it's true I
forget that so I am now the I'm now the
the chef in the prison which is from
Orange in the New Black is the New Black
yeah orange inside that black oh Orange
stealing the show with the jail costume
I got this at the Grove by the way
we we missed out not we missed out not
electing the Grove man we could be
having snow everywhere fake snow oh my
God people forgot it's not about the
politics he made the Grove have you just
been to the Grove people don't know what
are we talking about
mayor of L.A Rick Rosa for America Russo
have you been to the mall it's I'm
telling you it's heaven and it's the
heaven and all that Caruso also did
Americana right yes of course his malls
are amazing but we can't let Mall
tycoons take over our country and we
could have we could have fake snow in
July everywhere and you [__] this up did
you not see Back to the Future too when
Biff takes over the town and this turns
everything into a casino and a
motorcycle gangs run the city that's
where we'd be headed that's not too bad
I like when you unfold the three movies
you've seen it is like
and then in Sunset Boulevard there was
no talk she wanted no talking pictures
which would be good for you since
there's no writers thank you you don't
have to read no talking pictures like
films
yeah I mean okay I was like talking
pictures
I'm like I gotta read more this is crazy
so we are not um standing with Caruso
for um leadership
it's also I say I say we go back to the
future
okay I'm gonna [__] my dad or whatever
happens in it no no then like someone
banged their mom he's he's attracted no
you don't want to bring your mom because
you [__] sends him out we're talking
about now we're going back to episode
one where his mom has a crush on him
they're not called episodes I know that
did I say that yeah well oh my God
you're you're bombing at this writer
straight oh my God is it television or
movies is it tell back in time
um by the way there is a Back to the
Future Musical coming to Broadway which
I'm very excited are you gonna cry I yes
I will cry I only cry at musicals when
biflings and make out of this I have
questions why do you think that only
Asians have enough balls to put uh
parent [__] their own child into a
storyline like back to this spoiling
this movie for me and you keep spoiling
this also that's very disrespectful to
our new hire Liz who is Asian you did
not ask her if she identifies this age
oh I'm sorry we've been down here before
I actually just assumed that I wait Liz
what is your ethnic heritage
um Vietnamese hell yeah all right um so
basically like you guys have all seen
old boy right I haven't seen it because
you've spoiled it for me oh my God and
then I forget
it's only been for 25 years is that 25
years it's like 20 years old old boy is
like a yeah it's pretty old by now I'll
say this and again absolutely no
disrespect is meant this is my
anti-racism stance
get ready Tick Tock 20 years the things
that Asians will do in porn they do take
it further than the white folks 100 yeah
100 you really go I see what you guys
are doing I like it but it's a lot so is
that is that your category on PornHub no
but there's certain things that they'll
do that I think is kind of like I want
to know I'll tell you what I like go
ahead okay so what I look for my
category occasionally lately it's just
been asianly
occasionally this is pretty Annie
careful rubbing off on it's the pun
couch
get me off
um It's when
um eight Japanese men one girl and
they're using
20 types different Contraptions on her
and she's like just she can't stand that
she's coming so much but she is also not
like res it's a whole thing I know what
you mean but they're just using they're
just one upping each Contraption I know
what you mean and she's like
this can I can I make a suggestion of
why I think you like this oh wait Liz
just resigned no she agreed I saw her
agreeing I will tell you listen what I
think I think I have a theory behind
this because I also like stuff like that
because I think it's you know they're
really coming it's not fake coming
they can't stop they're like it's like
hurting them they're coming so much can
the record show my face at this and no
disrespect to your no when we're talking
about porn no we cannot change she's
trying to get put in AI porn look at her
do that but
you lost me at contract
contract I'm talking about you know
first you start with a small little
rabbit then onto the bigger thing then
on to the thing with some other things
attached to it and it just gets cooler
and cooler and more cooler
I mean look at her for someone but so
that's not what you're talking about
when you're looking at Asian porn no and
I'm like in porn oh I can I guess are
you into hentai you like when octopuses
no stop and stop guessing Okay
I know what her least favorite thing is
what nipple clamps I am so nipple
sensitive that like and yes that's
correct but any I think porn should be
about the human body no octopus no you
know chains like let's let's touch skin
to skin baby I don't feel comfortable HR
I'm not comfortable wait can we go back
to back to the future for a second
because um the one movie you've seen yes
we can do you guys know this scene where
like Biff is basically trying to
sexually assault Lorraine and they're
like in the car and he's like come on
come on like it's like a very iconic
like a salty rapey scene
I when that's your favorite porn
whenever Dave is like trying to get
donut to like cuddle or kiss him like I
always see Biff in the rain it's like so
sad it is forcing a dog to love you as
like a really like weak sad moment and
we've all been there right we're all
there right now
like I'm your I got I was wait let's go
you're our toy you're our toy he's so
floppy he very rarely resists wait while
we're talking about dogs I really need
to just like ask
all of us kind of feel like there's no
way we could love a human baby more than
we love our dog right I can't believe
every day of the capacity I have to love
my dog the courage it takes to get out
of bed in the morning while I'm cuddling
my dog I can't believe I do it I can't
believe I do it but people always say
they have kids and they don't love their
dog as much is that true Pete I don't
have you don't have a dog
where are his dogs
Jacob is very offended
but you didn't like get together with
your wife and get a dog
they like got to meetings no dogs too
much work forever two kids too much work
don't stop saying two so much Liz too
much Liz do you have kids I don't have
kids do you have dogs uh my family has
dogs but they're not technically mine
yeah you don't relate to this
conversation she's like she's like kind
of disgusted My Heart is Open what does
222 mean it means like um alignment and
I put it in the center of me because
like a line and it's like an angel
number so she was like and peaches said
to a million times oh my God were you
reading her necklace
dogs are too much I have two kids
Kyla do you feel like you could love a
human baby more than you love your dog
there's no way yeah there's no way maybe
equally I think we're all just not moms
and I think that when we're moms will
definitely love her because I talked to
you it's like 100 I'm sorry that makes
me want to not have a baby I don't want
to love donut less Wait no that's not
true because I talked to Ethan Klein and
Ela Klein about this and I was like do
you because they were obsessed with your
dogs before children and they said they
were equally obsessed with their dogs
today so that gives me hope
you I guess ideally you have the
situation where your dog loves your baby
and wants to cuddle with it that I think
is the one you want you know there's
like those are cute videos oh my God
it's like you don't want the dog that's
jealous of your baby like SWAT your own
dog what about the baby that's jealous
of the dog I have seen this I once went
to this guy I was working with his house
how old do you think babies can be 35.
and this little like toddler boy and
they had the cutest dog and oh she was
so cute I loved her so much and I was
like oh my God to the kid like don't you
love your dog and he just like
he like made a face and like walked away
and then like went like this and then
his dad was like yeah he's kind of
jealous of the dog and I was like what
the [__] okay so what's wrong with you I
dated a boy back this is one of my
potential Brothers Maybe
this was the boy I told you the reason
like I couldn't have gone to an abortion
clinic faster because he basically like
I went to his home and I saw that he had
his dog chained up like and it was his
grandma's dog all day little brother it
wasn't it couldn't I was like there's no
that's also what made me think he cannot
be my brother because I think
genetically like we cannot be the same
person because I love dogs everyone in
my family loves dogs I'm like I don't
think we're related because clearly you
don't like dogs but he did tell me that
there he has a deep resentment for dogs
because his dad was used to breed German
Shepherds so there was always 12 to 15
German Shepherds German Shepherds
they're so great though yeah but his dad
was so obsessed with him and he was a
neglectful father to this guy but was so
just hyper focused on his dogs and so he
was like when I look at dogs I look at
like competition I have a question
our Origins yeah I have a question about
you have the like bad guy
did he like animals was he like one of
those murderers that like loved animals
but killed people
um I I haven't actually seen him you
know he's a pretty good um animal
caretaker yeah you like you're like
listen we've got a dog sitter's on house
arrest he's got to walk he's got to let
the dogs out he's not gonna be able to
walk them I know it's so funny out of
all of my uncles this is the uncle I
feel like you guys would get along the
most why listen he is he is a murderer
hello look at me I really like he's such
a great time and also like when he is
loyal to you like he'll kill anyone for
you did he murder like mob style like
gang style oh he killed his own brother
in broad daylight using so you're ready
to sever the his vertebrae wait why
um it was like a money dispute in the
family but then
um yeah Jules is about to [__] you up
he turned himself in eventually he's
like arrest me now or else I'm gonna
kill my sister as well which is not my
mom another this is kalila saying she
wants us dead you'd love it
because one machete three people have
fun I'd love to introduce you but he has
some really cool prison stories because
Prison in the Philippines is not the
same obviously they let you out yeah
right he serves like 20 years which is
probably not enough I'm so like I really
feel like but you know I still send him
money you just get to like come out
again I still send him money you guys
like I fully support his family I don't
like that that means we're sort of
supporting him too
people deserve forgiveness and we we
need to Kim Kardashian says we need to
have a path towards uh life after prison
I'm so excited for Esther to go through
her going to law school
Kardashians wait nursing school's out
the door it's law school nursing school
was was a was a made a pipe dream a
made-up live dream
[Music]
you know when you've been stewing on a
health problem for a while and colloid
was not available and I'm not available
and your group your group chat your
reliable group chats not available to
diagnose you yeah and also they'll say
steak to go to that because everyone you
know is an idiot and not a doctor well
back in the day we didn't really have
options but now we have ZocDoc ZocDoc is
everything I love ZocDoc sock dog is my
favorite
um one of my favorite sponsors I used it
for I had a toothache I got a dentist
Within by 11AM the next day that took my
insurance it was an awesome dentist I
knew it was going to be a good because
of the reviews I walked in it was like
the best place in the world
and then I did it with my neurologist
too it's like the coolest the best I
love ZocDoc ZocDoc is the only free app
that lets you find and book doctors who
are patient reviewed take your insurance
and are available when you need them and
treat almost every condition Under the
Sun you need a dermatologist they're
there you need an oncologist they're
there everybody's on there and there's
no more Dr roulette or scouring the
internet for questionable reviews with
ZocDoc you have a trusted guide to
connect you to your favorite doctor that
you just haven't met yet
book an appointment with a few TAPS in
their app and start feeling better
faster with ZocDoc with ZocDoc there are
no alarms and no surprises choose from
thousands of patient review doctors and
Specialists browse doctor profiles
upload and verify your insurance
information and get the care you need go
to zocdoc.com trash and download the
ZocDoc app for free then find and book a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that
zocdoc.com trash zocdoc.com trash
whether you're new to cannabis or an Old
Pro there's no denying that many of the
products on the market seem iffy at best
and when you do and when you want to
relax iffy is the last way you want to
feel mood puts an end to guessing games
it's a hundred percent federally legal
Delta 8 and Delta 9 THC you can have
shipped straight to you no doctors no
waiting just Affordable Legal THC and
for a Time mood is giving our listeners
free Delta 9 gummies and 20 off your
first order visit hello dot com and use
our code trash Tuesday and what I love
about mood is that they have different
strains for specific moods so for
example if I want to seize the day they
have an energized strain if I want to
get in the zone because I have work to
do they have a focus strain other moods
are creative they have a euphoric erotic
they have a sleepy one chill body
Soother which has been coming through
for me lately do you do erotic and chill
at the same time
how did you I thought you'd never asked
are you ready for a good time without
the guesswork order your THC products
from mood today and for 20 off your
first order and free gummies go to
hellomood.com news promo code trash
Tuesday that's hello
m-o-o-d.com promo code trash Tuesday for
20 off your order and free gummies
look I've talked to people who've been
on reality TV and it's like the way they
edit you may not be the truth is this
you trying to pretend like you talk to
the Kardashians yeah I was talking to
Kim this is something on my way to work
that was weird like Chris really does
weird stuff with that
um yeah I know you know how much Kendall
loves me I would never sign up for a
reality show Strictly for that like
being edited a certain way yeah you have
to like you really have to surrender too
yeah but we have a friend Jenna who is
on a reality show
um endurance it was for children a
Survivor for on Discovery Kids that's so
amazing and you know what and she
probably crushed on it she did crush and
she is was so immune to any of the drama
she says that like the producers would
keep asking her about other people and
stuff like she kind of proved there's a
way to game it where you just
I mean I guess you make for like a not
that exciting like as a watcher of
reality TV I'm very upset yeah no I kind
of just play in but she just like was
like I don't know like she just didn't
yeah what they wanted I've been
befriending a lot of the reality stars
I'm fans with are fans of and they are
so
they forgive each other so fast it's
kind of amazing like they talk on the
show on each other or after like off the
show they're not like it's like they
kind of have like a clean slate like for
the challenge
um they kind of Clean Slate at each
season is it because they know that hey
the cameras are on we're supposed to be
you know a heightened version of us I do
think I think it's that I also think
that they're all athletes on this one
show so they're so competitive that way
that that's what they care about is like
who can beat each other physically oh so
it's like at the end of uh you like uh
um MMA fight how they can talk [__]
promote the fight and then afterwards
they hug it out after just beating the
[__] out of each other sometimes they
have like sometimes they hold grudges
and stuff but it also has been going on
for like over 20 years and it's they've
they have been their whole lives have
been reality TV I would also guess
there's probably some sort of a like
maybe trauma Bond or maybe just bond
from like being on the show together
yeah that afterwards it's like yeah
maybe you were just competitive with
this person but you have so much more in
common with them than like anyone else
invited as well I remember when someone
was telling me this like about going
to New York as a comedian and like a
friend of mine said like he went to New
York to do stand-up and he would run
into people he knew from the LA comedy
scene but wasn't that close with but
like when you see them in New York
you're like oh my God it's so good to
see like it heightens the block or
whatever that's how I felt when I came
to La I was close with Naper gazian in
New York but when we saw each other like
across the room at the Hollywood improv
we were just like there's a different
level of like New York [__] talking that
La didn't have at that time for me
and we just got together and it was like
like just so fun just on the phone all
the time like ever just meeting each
other just like had that that Bond I
have not talked to him in a while
hi congratulations mate his I watched
his last message the funniest it's so
good he's so funny he you know what's
frustrating about being friends with him
he you'll go do sets with him and stuff
or you'll be like hang out with him he's
like oh you should do it and it's like
yeah but you like you saying something
that I just said on stage would be so
funny do you know what I mean like he
just has like such a way of Naturally
Speaking In jokes if you want to know
how far he's come in his career I did
Comics Unleashed with him and so yeah
that was not a did you come in with a
liege
not a highlight for anything Comics
Unleashed is so funny did I tell you
guys that
um
I ran into an ex not Bobby
um looking my absolute [__] worse I
think that's good for you and and you
know what you're not wrong I had a sweat
mustache I had just woken up I was
stumbling over to like a nearby like
grocery store I was crusty I didn't
brushed my hair like it was like think
about like when you walk out and you're
like I hope to God no one sees me this
way because I'm taking a chance I'm
going out into the wild looking at the
worst I've ever looked like please God
don't strike me down baby he struck me
down and all I heard was Hey kalila and
I just kept walking I just kept walking
and then he caught up to me and by the
time I just it honestly is not a great
feeling but you're right I did grow from
that I was so nervous I was like just
sweating everywhere and I was like I'm
so sorry you like had to see me like
this like oh no you said it yeah it was
really bad when you gain weight you mean
someone you see your ex boyfriend like
ah
it's been crazy
right like you're like you know I did
that once with my high school ex this
was the last time I saw him and it was
right after college is that why he
locked you out he's like I don't want
her eating all of my Rice Krispies and I
had as as everyone who knows me knows I
put on a lot of weight my freshman year
of college new girl was that when you're
on new girl she was a new girl
and I remember saw him I literally told
the classic lie I can't believe I did
thyroid problem no I said it's for a
role
I said yeah I'm putting on weight for a
part I really do you should have taken
that one to the Grave that's an
important that's worse than the check
mark I was 18. we were like and if we
asked what role what if he had asked
what role he didn't and that's you could
have been like this roll and then run
off you probably would have been like oh
I can't talk about it right now I don't
I don't know I would have just said like
an original play I was in the theater
program so I was like there's still some
reality there you're forever in the
theater program by the way thank you
sometimes I forgot and then I'm like how
could I forget wow that is such a life
hack I mean it wouldn't have worked for
me because what am I gonna say like I'm
doing a themed podcast we have to gain
weight for one episode I'm getting into
character for something like what the
thyroid thyroid by the way the right eye
lime
autoimmune the real [__] G cool thing
to do is not have any excuse and just be
so confident be like in your head you're
like yeah I look like [__] I don't care
I'm beautiful yeah you you would think
but if you're caught off guard if you're
caught off guard you don't have like I
I'm not present in the moment I don't
have like the right Tools in that moment
so the sweat mustache it is you know
um you know how like the writers on
strike do you think that there could be
a version of it where women go on strike
and we just all vow to not have sex with
a man like until our demands are met
what are our demands that I don't know
and like but there's no way we would all
agree on our demand yeah the demands
wouldn't be a universal thing I think
this has to be a solo ticketing this is
a solo ticket a picketing for one
you guys won't join me in the refuses
I'm not fighting for you to get
something weird something so weird so
you're all about withholding sex unless
I want a penthouse no I'm not all about
that it was just a crazy idea from a
strike no withholding sex is not healthy
it's not okay I don't I don't that's
even in that outfit or using it as a way
to get someone to do something is that
is not the beginning of the end I think
so for sure
um
speaking of I wanted it has nothing to
do with this but before when you were
talking when your ringtone was going off
I wanted to ask you guys because I lose
my phone that's why I was asking how
messy you guys are I I lose my phone and
my own filth all the time like it's gone
as I walk in it's gone I like picturing
it caked on to filth like it's on the
middle yeah it's a barnacle
I have to use my eye my watch because
I'm like I can't possibly my least
favorite word in the world is Barnacles
do you know that to be one and also hate
the word Esther can I tell you something
a fun fact about Barnacles I guess they
look cute in baby blue
hahaha
a fun fact I learned in Marine Biology
class about Barnacles it goes to marine
biology classes with Dr Gaga it changed
my life and who offers that where does
that offer Dr Gago was the greatest Gaga
is that a cute way of saying goggles you
know goggle actually crazy is that the
male version of Lady Gaga Mr Google he
just shows his like underwear yeah Dr
Gaga was hot and um he had a Spanish
accent as well anyways the fun thing I
learned about Barnacles is that if we
were if we were to find a solution for
um so that boats no longer have bar like
if there was a way to shave off
Barnacles from boats if there was a
chemical that we could come up with we
would all be billionaires like billions
oh that's like the main problem yeah
because it causes a lot of like Rick's a
lot of Havoc with like big ships yeah
and how many billionaires are So Thirsty
to come up with some kind of a toxic
chemical to make them more money but to
hurt the oceans to prevent that's like
that like Jeff Bezos is going to be all
over that
can we give some evil ladies some credit
we should who there's female School
shooters now I mean not school Shooters
they age into it but there's women doing
crazy things driving into protests come
on really it could be crazy too yes yeah
snapped it's like my favorite show ever
I will I do want to say that I'm
actually going to sound I have to go
back on something I just said
because I do know stuff about Barnacles
too because I know you read biology
thing in Hawaii I went to the main menu
yes Esther fomo much we know about
Barnacles that's why we can handle I
think I'm okay
so okay so a good thing that Barnacles
do is it helps you track them track the
population of
um of Wales in the Hawaiian
sea fair because they have a lot because
they go through because they take
pictures they go on these like whale
watching yeah things and they take
pictures of their flukes yeah and um and
then people like me paid to go to this
thing and I would just sift through all
these you'd have like a year like it'd
be like 1970 and then you'd have 1983 or
something and you would go through all
of those and see if you had any matching
ones and if you've got a match they
could like tell that on that year they
had that was I guess oh I love that so
you can even maybe age them it would be
yeah that's how they did it it would be
like because some of them had tags but
most of it was just Barnacles and like
scars yeah I wish there was a way we
could clean off a lot of barnacles off
these things don't you ever do the cord
clearing things I always do that like if
you're upset with someone you like
imagine Barnacles on like a cord with
them and you just clean it off did you
ever do that I love Barn you got to go
to YouTube baby you can do a lot on
YouTube like
you know how like people will tell jat
chat gbt like explain this to me like
I'm dumb
I feel like you just explained it like
you're dumb
you feel like you chatted made me say it
wait you are a weird Chad gbt honestly
I'm an AI boy like I create it all I
have ai software okay so this is what I
want to say about ringtones I lose my
phone all the time
and so what I started doing is I go hey
Siri play who let the dogs out and then
from a pile of clothes it's like who let
the dogs out it's like the [__] best
wait that's a really it's the best it's
not smart it's the best but also I
forgot to tell you when the
um acupuncturers came over oh yeah man
tan isn't it
and I love him by the way it's
incredible he did come over though oh
okay so every week I had him over a
million what did you get done
he did he was doing like blood
circulation and stuff nothing I mean it
was like there's just yeah but he's
awesome and he did a lot of like deep
tissue that actually really helped
that's amazing yeah he was so good but
um while he was there Todd set up our
Alexa to say two things when
um
when like something beeps it goes for
the love of God can someone get this
which is not that big a deal right but
then if someone call or if someone
coughs oh it's three things if someone
coughs it goes um
it goes can you stop coughing I'm trying
to flick my bean and I kept saying that
while he was there and it was so awkward
I'm like I can't like say I'm like in
pins you know like I can't was he
coughing
he was not coughing I was coughing I'm
like stabbed and things are flowing in
weird ways but um and then also when
Randy barks it says
um Randy or not cool or tough oh are you
guys are really having like you're
utilizing Alexa correctly I feel like I
have no fun with oh if I could tell you
we're gonna have to bleep everything out
here by the way I'm also utilizing your
Alexa uh I I had living inside of it you
I honestly you are a creep I'll never
forget when you wanted my location
I'll never get over it how scary is that
when one of your weird little friends
wants her location it's for no good it's
it's did you at one point share your
location never I don't think no I have
it with a lot of it she really and you
don't mind that no I love it she wants
it she's the one starting prize people
like I've had I mean I surprised you
once and we didn't talk for three years
that was different that was you hiding
in a closet
this is more like someone's at a
restaurant and I'm like
oh and then you fake that you ran into
them you faked that it was a you're like
oh my God I was just here too yeah I no
I've never that's good career movie oh
God that got really far doing that
really yes Spike having locations yes
she used to she wasn't location sharing
but she would go through like she would
meet casting directors and she would
like follow them on stuff and she would
like find out their favorite music and
like where they're gonna be and she
would like shop like listening to it
oh I mean she is surviving she's
thriving strategy
strategy I thought it was nasty but it's
a little bit wild I thought I was crazy
for pretending to like Lord of the Rings
in high school to get a guy to like me
like that is nice did you actually watch
it to bring up Gollum when you were so
close
it's high school it's bold
um would you if someone because I know
that sometimes you get two obviously
you're hot you're going through your hot
girl face you're very hot I'm just
teasing you but we know sometimes you
get teas we get told you look like
different characters
grew it wasn't Groot or what it grew or
something grew oh yes on uh Tick Tock a
lot of teenagers called me Gru would you
do a part if it was like you had to be
like an ugly guy in it but it was like a
cool part if I liked the part yeah I
would like if they were like we want you
to be Golem's like wife like the Bride
of God I would do it's yes if it was
cool I I would yeah if it's like you
know what Gollum looks like yeah bring
up just a reminder
but also I hear something
Gollum is fine sometimes he's cute he's
not he's iconic you know who he is that
movie came out how many years ago we're
still talking about him so
you can spin it she's got that Hollywood
spin baby here's the thing about this
Esther you're fandom is gonna like for
the rest of your life they're gonna be
like that's gollum's wife
but every time I have to go
or something yeah that would be actually
so ideal I could drop the the trying to
be pretty act and just lean into who I
really am but you've established
yourself as pretty so now maybe wear a
bald cap or something I will say that
without hair is that's hard didn't you
oh you are a cap on here I would say
that all of us will be disgusting in
ball caps and maybe we should have an
episode where we I would do that not a
full app because I promise you that the
organization that supports alopecia will
cancel us all immediately why we're
going our Alabama everything you do it's
alopecia awareness but look at what all
we've done for a balding awareness with
our old
technician
oh Carlos was here oh you know what I
was thinking today too I was thinking
about when you were like hey guys like
um when girls like put their hair up and
ponytails do you think of [__] I was
saying like only when Carlos does it
just like a [__]
I was also thinking about that didn't
you like ever go like try to like mess
with your ex-boyfriend in college I
should probably talk to her
and like I remember my friend Tara and I
we like our our ex-boyfriends were both
going to be at the same party and we
like we're kind of still into them and
it was like will we get back oh that's
fun and we went like pigtails and they
might have had girls that's sad but we
were 18 what are you gonna do yeah I
think that's just the game you play at
that age but I did want to ask you guys
um what is your number one or maybe top
three breakup songs
Dancing On My Own by Rob Robin okay
great one Esther
um [__]
um bulletproof this time baby I'm LaRue
LaRue yeah but how old is that song
about 15.
you haven't been through a breakup for
that another day for 27 years that was
the oh yes those are both for a big
breakup that happened whose name rhymes
with inch Cliff
the factory to listen music dancing
right that's so funny listen Robin dude
are you kidding like having to go to
comedy clubs knowing like your ex is
there and he's so mean he's so mean to
you I needed to blast Robin Dancing On
My Own to exist
um there's this one okay so I'll throw
it all the way back
um there's uh Whitney Houston
um then we almost have it all there's uh
the other one um
I keep forget we're not in love anymore
Is It Michael McDonald
and the third one is the Sheena Easton
um
almost over you those are my three
classes
you're like I gotta get red band back
um I have okay go west
um right is that it Go West think of
wishful thinking
yeah
I would like I can't oh also Katy Perry
Circle the Drain Circle a drain or
asleep during foreplay what are the
lyrics to Cambridge thinking
I don't need to fall at your feet just
cause you cut me to the Bone it's the
best I don't know this one and wait and
even if Katy Perry never really over is
a good one
um that one see that's what made me sad
your breakup choices make me sad sad
never really over it's a great one
there's oh my God I have the number one
one what is it um Bonnie Raitt I Can't
Make You Love oh my God I love Bonnie
Raitt that's a really that is the number
one and every cover anyone's ever done
God that's a really sad one you know
what's um we are we're not none of us
are aligned or maybe I'm the outsider
here obviously Since You've Been Gone by
Kelly Clarkson yeah it's like a big one
but maybe
I think she had a daddy one wasn't a
daddy one but um I think scissors nobody
gets me is a girl I mean
Kill Bill Kill Bill is a good one but
that one again is still a little sad for
me but there's a line and says nobody
gets me which one where she goes hurry
hurry now stick it in before the
memories start to kick off so what's our
song
it's like so crude but also like I don't
know why that line makes sense well what
about our American Idol song her wait
says
Annie what is it
what the [__] why can't we talk about
this it's crazy that that happened okay
I think we should talk about it we have
to remember the song first but what's
the song what do you do I love it it's
like one of my favorite I can't like I'm
like blanking on words and lyrics how
can you mention a scissor lyric and it
not be I [__] him because I miss you
okay that's a good one too yeah what
about this is my Best Buy song like give
me some let's get on yeah like Empower
like female power ballads guys hear me
no but Annie
great one
when he sang that I went to the Prince
concert when he sang that it was all my
eyes yeah it's unbelievable you went to
Prince concert I did for 25 he kept the
tickets so affordable it was at the
Forum and he did it for like three
weekends straight and everyone could go
because the tickets were 25 bucks that's
so cool I saw him once in La like when I
first moved here I was at random was he
shorter or taller than you
like I didn't believe it was Prince
because of how short he was oh we really
yeah like I was like are you guys sure
like I just didn't understand that like
a celebrity could be short it was like
that um it was every time I've met a
celebrity I feel they were like you're
so short yeah I did see Alexander
Skarsgard once when I was me too
exciting about how tall he was me too
twice he is so I went with this ugly on
succession right now oh I know oh he's
on the third he's on succession and he's
killing it before Tick Tock when you
weren't watching that much TV what were
you doing
with your respect extra time
do you like lay and think
no I just watch a lot of TV and you
don't oh I watch movies like old movies
I re-watch a lot of old movies I uh and
you like re-watching movies you already
know what's gonna happen yes look I was
watching Sunset Boulevard last night
I uh
yeah movies social media play times
hang laughs with Dave
you know I learned in I had a therapy
session yesterday and what I learned
about myself is
do you know that when you're
intellectualizing your feelings and
you're like okay I feel this way because
it's actually a way to avoid feeling
your feelings I didn't know that I was
doing that my whole life when you try to
under when you try to find out why
you're feeling that so like the way the
way I talk about it yeah so like even
the way I talk about it on this podcast
where I'm like I'm this I'm that I'm
intellectualizing it and sometimes I
when I talk to people when I don't want
to
I I kind of phrase the way I'm feeling
it this is what I wrote
intellectualizing feelings and talking
about my feelings isn't the same as
feeling my feelings it's actually a way
to avoid them so because you're not
it's it's kind of I'm explaining to you
what is wrong with me but I'm actually
not presently you're like yeah I'm this
Associated they're like telling a story
about it exactly exactly I'm telling you
a story about my feelings I'm not
showing you my feelings how is that bad
it's because you're not feeling it
you're not processing you're yeah you're
not integrated so what I learned
yesterday that I'm not fully integrated
and so
can I explain to you what he explained
what she said to me so basically it's
like you have your fight flight freeze
Fawn which is your lizard brain that's
like right here and then you have your
limbic system which is your your middle
brain that's where all of your emotions
are and then the top of your brain is
like your Neo frontal cortex that's like
higher order thinking that that way
dance moves come from yes maybe but
that's where you critically think you're
able to assess you're able to actually
like the facts are up here okay when
you're living in these two lower parts
of your brain you're not factual you're
just surviving so that's where I live
most of the time that's why I'm not
fully integrated it's hard for me to
like be present in the moment
um I can only be I can only enjoy things
in retrospect where I'm like that was a
really good time but when I'm in that
time I'm not present because you're not
there you're thinking about another
thing I'm nervous I'm anxious I'm just
sort of getting through the moment I
definitely relate to this like I know
this I'm following Yeah so basically one
of the things I do that I have done in
therapy my whole life even to the point
where my therapist is like oh kalila if
she's not a great therapist she's like
Kyle is doing well she understands her
feelings she knows what they are she
knows what her key problems are because
I'm able to intellectualize and talk to
her about it but I'm not feeling it I'm
not healing you're like from afar
looking down exactly things and
experiences now
are you is it suffice to say that like
just being present is kind of like the
what would fix that the goal but to be
present to be fully integrated like to
be be like I am here I am feeling it all
is a lot of work and a lot of it I've
avoided my whole life it's just like
course correcting constantly it's hard
exactly you have to always like remember
when you're but it blew my mind because
I'm like I have a full understanding of
you know complex PTSD I have a full
understanding of what my my illness is
right but I have done almost zero
healing I've just talked about it my
whole life but I'm not feeling yet it's
MDR so that's what I just started does
it make you cry to do it
um
very very so like they always recommend
that you have like a safe person
afterwards to go on a walk with and to
kind of because it's a whole
reprocessing of your brain right and the
goal is to not see my EMDR therapist
forever you know hopefully as you know
as we go on she's like okay I think
you're actually at a good spot we don't
have to continue seeing each other
um so that's sorry that just that
sentence was really triggering we're
done
wait so are you do you think you're able
to be present now that like that you're
are you still working on it I'm still
working on it okay yeah so basically all
of this to say I've gotten so much value
out of just regular talk therapy because
I know
what's wrong with me but I haven't
really been able to heal those things
because just knowing about it isn't the
same as healing it and sometimes the why
it's like you're re-digging it up like
when you're looking for like the why of
everything and it's like you also I
remember seeing this thing on uh Netflix
where you know they do like the
explained series I don't know if it was
that one or whatever but it was like
memory and there was something on it
that was like basically like your memory
is false yeah you just don't remember
things correctly so it's like you know
we're digging back trying to figure out
why we feel this way why we went there
and it's like it's not even necessarily
the truth of what happened you know
exactly or it's been morphed into
whatever story we like telling ourselves
yeah but I think that's important too
like that's why you you reprocess these
things and because I think sometimes the
narrative you tell yourself is incorrect
and it's costing you a lot of suffering
today as an adult and if you process it
a different way how even if you re even
if you misremember it you're still
reprocessing it than making it so that
it no longer hurts you today what is an
example of reprocessing a memory like is
it literally just like you thinking of a
traumatic experience and like playing it
out going differently or is this
something different than that
um well I the way I understand EMDR is
you you have like two buzzies the two
buzzies you can have the thing
um it's it's kind of just like
repackaging like a narrative I think
yeah and kind of I don't think it's like
walking back into your trauma I mean
like I haven't done it long enough when
I did brain spotting it sure felt like
that and I was really like frightened
and scared and I couldn't come off that
feeling for a couple days but I think
when you do it with the right person it
can feel like heavy but like positive
did I have a question too did you go
back for more Academy in order to just
do one session I did one session and it
[__] like it really did so much but I
think I'm thinking about going maybe
like once a year
yeah because do they suggest you go in
like a series or is it just a one and
done um no it's not a one I mean the
goal like again is to especially for
people who are like at the end of their
like at the end of their world they're
having a lot of like deep like Suicidal
Thoughts those are the people who have
from what I understand like go like even
like once a week and then the goal is
then it's twice a month and then it's
once a month and then hopefully like
never again yeah and do you feel like
you you had such an impactful time that
you just didn't want to go back right
away yeah try something else I still
feel like I'm feeling like pretty
positive about it
um but I would like to maybe go again
this year to like kind of reinforce the
because it kind of just wiped my a lot
of my anxiety
but anyways
um
my point in all this is knowing what's
wrong with you doesn't mean
you know
you're is it's not enough yeah like
there's a lot more work and I think I've
just avoided that work because I'm like
well I know what's wrong with me right
that makes sense it does make sense that
to think like I know the problem so I
know it and so it's fine but like
yeah the actual healing part is more
tricky I would assume yeah and
especially for like you people like you
and I would like more complex PTSD
like I think what happens is that like
we know the story so well because we
tell it in jest a lot like we're always
like we repeat it you know it's it's
part of our thing we make it but it's
like these are things that actually
behind the doors
yeah I found like a lot like I do a
little bit of a joke and stuff on stage
about stuff yeah and I like talking
about it to like help people but it is
like
[Music]
but when we when I tell you about like
getting bittled like Annie and I like
every week right yeah like I really want
the audience to know that settled every
week though so I don't find that to
it's not disposable information that no
longer hurts us it's just that in that
moment we're intellect we're telling you
this is what happened we're
intellectualizing it but I can promise
you that like when I hit those topics
with a therapist I am inconsolable I
cannot breathe I vomit these because I
am just telling you what happened to me
and I've been so trained in you know
like making light of it but it's almost
disassociate it's dissociating I'm
avoiding the feeling when someone
validates
your like circumstance of what happened
to you I was talking to things oh my God
it's over like I was you're I'm like how
am I crying again about this it's so
crazy because that's exactly it's such a
it's such an intense thing to have
happen to you and then I think the
reason we talk about it so much not is
not just PTSD or whatever it is
definitely also to find like a funny
angle to it and like make it lighter
which it doesn't always do but I think
it's because it's something that is so
taboo and we weren't supposed to talk
about you know we're supposed to keep a
secret I think it's like kind of taking
back the night to just keep talking
about it I agree with that even though I
don't have that experience but I I know
I've said this before thank you
but like one of the reasons
I was reading this this is so cheesy but
I was reading this book called start
with your why and it's about like
when you do something you have to really
anyone who does something and they're
good at it they have a why they have a
reason why they're doing it and reading
that book I was like oh my God I know
exactly so easily what my why is for
trash Tuesday it's like we're three
women who get together and like talk
about traumatic bad things but like in a
like what you were saying just like
owning it and taking the shame away from
it being vulnerable and I even though it
it hurts me so much to hear that like
these things cause you pain like I still
I don't know like I am proud of what
this podcast does because I mean how
many people do you meet on the road that
are like I was molested too and like
they find so much comfort Frozen ones
what's up I'm making us earrings we're
gonna have earrings on the road like is
that still okay that that's like
something that I'm proud of and that
like like yeah okay I think it's just
always important we are talking about
all these things that we're forward
moving in our healing and we're you know
yeah and I think that that never ends if
you're constantly talking about it and
if it's something that's hurting you but
you're you know you're not addressing it
in your real life like like that's
that's a little bit concerning but I do
think it's like that people come up and
they're like I never it'll be like a lot
of older women like I love when people
come with their moms and stuff it's the
best and they'll just be like you know
I just never knew I could talk about
this so it's it's awesome or even our
boy slugs yeah yeah oh yeah
but that is I that gave me the chills
people saying to I never knew I could
talk about this like that I could cry
like that is
I'm like so mad that so many people have
to like stuff things down and feel shame
I know and it's so sad when it's like
cash your card
or not [__]
come on Tick Tock there's a lot of
molested people in this line so many
people gotta I want to make shirts that
say like are like where on the shirt was
I touched and I signed like the part
that were diddled and also for those of
you at home who weren't molested I got
you
those of us come during me and reach
home Alaska we survived each other we
survived not being molested which was
also hard I know I'm so sorry this
happened to you thank you are you okay
this is a weird topic and I kind of
almost don't want to bring it up because
it's I think should be a bigger
conversation we'll talk more about it
next week or whatever but like
there's a lot of
feminists that are like anti-birth
control like the birth control pill
which is seems crazy because the birth
control pill is like what gave women
freedom and it was a huge part of like
the women's Liberation Movement Like
finally we could have sex and not be
scared of a pregnancy but there are
people who say that
that like I oh
that the reason like choking
insects and like basically we're trying
to introduce a level of danger that has
been taken away by the pill so when you
were actually choking insects yes
choking no in not insects
in sex or during sex yeah I was like are
you just choking insects like I never
even thought about it
my childhood given so much difference
you know after that I can't believe she
didn't hear incest I was like you didn't
hear and says oh you heard it wait this
I'm telling you guys please follow me
this is so blowing my mind like I will
not follow you follow me back okay so
basically like sex was hot and like
dangerous because you might get the girl
pregnant and you might get pregnant and
it's like ah and that made it hot right
but then with birth control that's gone
so there's this theory that like that is
why now there's like choking and you're
like introducing new elements of danger
because that is gone and it's just I'm
kind of like
that seems real or is this like a smart
feminist spin on the fact that they are
taking away all this stuff from us how
do we make it seem like this is a good
thing [__] this is already happening I'm
trying to see if I believe that choking
exists because we're trying to up the
danger or if there's true science behind
like erotic asphyxiation I guess there
must be I'm too because men do it too
right they choke themselves and certain
men do like being you know but do you
feel like okay because I've had choki
situation it's not the actual choking
it's not it's like rapey feelings
hey it's not like Oh I like that the air
is not going oh yeah it doesn't make me
come harder but I know for some men
maybe it does I I don't you're saying
it's just the hand on your
yeah that's what I always assumed but
the guys that are like hanging
themselves and like that's it's
obviously like that no for them so I
assumed what you're saying but I do
think that it is actually true that
there is like a like women like to be
choked because of the asphyxiation
yeah I've never so I've been choked
pretty bad and like almost to like gotta
guess passed out we're gonna go that way
didn't make my [__] better it kind of put
me in my head of oh my goodness oh my
God I slept through it
looked down at a wet spot like I already
came
um yeah so I but I do understand what
you're saying about the birth control
pill it's kind of the same idea as like
I recent my one of my friends her
husband recently had a vasectomy and I
was like well is sex still exciting
equally as exciting as hot knowing that
there isn't like you're you're never
there's not a danger for having like
another kid again because his chamber is
empty right it and she was like to be
determined I will report back like so
after men get a vasectomy like even in
my most like feminist ideas there is
something there that kind of makes me
feel like oh like you couldn't possibly
get me pregnant like anymore it it there
is a part of me that does consider that
that I'm like I feel like we don't
realize it but that does add this like
subconscious like hotness to sex but do
you think that's why when women are
older and not as fertile they're not as
into sex because there's no no but I I
don't know but [__] I don't like
saying this but that's why like men are
biologically attracted to younger women
because they're more fertile which I
hate and we're gonna change that somehow
what by looking like a kid Forever
by freezing at this weird age looking
so is that the running Theory then what
by feminists certain feminists that's
one thing I saw and it [__] checked
out properly yeah it's interesting
because it is
is it like yeah I think I haven't
thought about it in so long because I
haven't been like so afraid of a
pregnancy in so long but then recently I
had unprotected sex and thought there
was a chance I could be Prego and I
wasn't and and they're like I gotta
direct it get some free birthday I gotta
get the word out there
no I don't know I gotta go deep I gotta
get invested I don't know it's just like
it's hot to be scared of getting
pregnant I'll say that it's youthful um
but you're right there is that element
that's super hot about
do you feel like upset that you can't
impregnito
[Laughter]
I'm trying it's not hot anyway it's so
weird that you think I don't have sperm
like that's weird you know I know you
look like
you know what I would allow it if you
took someone's like okay and then turkey
basted me with it or you could just like
finger the like you know inseminate how
do you guys think you would parent a kid
together
[Laughter]
and that's why I'm attracted to you yes
it probably like has nothing to do
Freedom too guys I know we do too we do
too I want to be a dive I should I'm
going to bring my bit back about how
much I would be a dad you have like
really I would love that Dad oh my God
no it's not fair it's crazy it seems
incredible the men in our business can
have a kid without getting pregnant
they're like you guys there's this anime
called The Way of the house husband and
you just start having Dave and Todd
watch it it's like this I think Todd
might have written it
that's why Todd Pickett
but yeah it's it's so silly but it's
called The Way of the house husband and
there's something kind of cute about it
it's an avatar parody
no it's just an anime it's like they're
really short couple minutes long oh
that's so cute yeah super cute and he's
like so violent and he's kind of nuts
he's like an ex-criminal but now he's a
house husband wait see okay like
that's I'm that's hot it doesn't look
like Todd and on that note
may you stay with all the colors of the
wind we'll see you next week with a
brand new episode
bye guys
foreign
[Music]